hey guys justin here with a gamespot
news update today Nintendo confirmed the
smash brothers wii u release date for
both the US and the UK Friday December
5th marks the date super smash brothers
will ship across Europe while it comes
to the US two weeks earlier on November
21st two additional Ryu bundles have
also been lined up by Nintendo UK the
first being amiibo NFC powered plastic
toys that can interact with certain
Nintendo games the other bundle comes
with a gamecube controller adapter
allowing the classic control pad to be
used on Wii U if you already have a
system and you're hoping to get your
hands on the new run of Smash Brothers
themed gamecube controllers those will
be available starting december fifth and
don't forget to order the gamecube
controller adapter as well the
controllers are being remanufactured for
smash brothers wii u but they won't plug
directly into your wii u nintendo reveal
that's lunch plans whilst is closing
that the handheld version super smash
brothers for 3ds has sold an impressive
2.8 million copies worldwide since its
release and stay tuned to gamespot com
for all of your twenty-four-seven gaming
news needs